all right let's move on to titans and
the ravens you're on overtime you're on
fire overtime hey man i'm feeling good
it's thanksgiving week you know you know
there the cdc is recommending that you
limit gatherings that's that's right in
my wheelhouse i just want to sit alone
with a turkey by myself i can't wait
until thursday when i can do that one
leg in each hand suddenly flashing the
middle finger to you while i grip the
bottom of the turkey leg that's what i'm
gonna be doing on thursday okay all
right titans and the ravens it looked
like the ravens were going to win the
game it looked like they were in control
because they were in the first half
titan's offense wasn't getting anything
done the ravens were up halftime
adjustments and out came the titans my
goodness
and we're going to give the titans their
appropriate praise and credit but i
think the headline
from this one is ding dong the ravens
are dead i and look they're not
completely dead but they will be dead if
they lose on thursday night to the
steelers six and four after 14 and two
here is lamar jackson who's had some
interesting sound bites all year long
here's his latest on his belief that
everyone's out to get the ravens
you know we just had two losses in a row
um games we you know we should have won
uh we had the hiccups in the game
but we still got to keep fighting
through it you know that team would look
like that team wanted them more than us
you know they were playing physical uh
when we went up i feel like you know we
just took off without the gas but we
just got to keep it going finish teams
yeah look i i he also added at some
point everyone wants us to lose i don't
understand why he thinks that i i but
you know when when you feel like
everything is crumbling around you
and maybe you do slide into that mindset
and it was several weeks ago where he
made the comment about the chiefs being
their kryptonite which was not good a
couple of weeks ago the idea that people
are calling out their plays when they're
on the field trying to execute their
offense that's not good and i think they
just they just need to get this t this
team has lost something and i think it
started with the steelers game yeah a
game that they believe they they they
kicked the crap out of the steelers
they would use a different term than
that privately yeah and they still lost
i i think you you you easily can lose
your edge and i feel like they've lost
their edge yeah i i do too
there's something about you know their
mojo their magic whatever it is you know
yeah they lost that steelers game they
went to new england they went uh new
england this isn't the same new england
you know we've seen we're more talented
than them they took that for granted got
punched in the mouse lost lost that
football game and then yesterday i mean
hey i'll kind of agree with what lamar
said there
i mean
the game's 2113 the ravens are
controlling it the ravens got the ball
he throws that deep pass to duvernay
that gets intercepted
and it's like the titans controlled the
game from that point on i mean the the
ravens defense just got absolutely
bullied for the second week in a row
where the titans did whatever they
wanted and now that you know the ravens
did some did a good job of ending some
of those drives that make him end up in
field goals and got lucky because of
really titan's mistakes and bad snaps
and things like that but
wow i mean it's just not very often you
see a ravens football team get pushed
around two weeks in a row and last week
and last you know yesterday excuse me
just never be able to stop the bleeding
at any point i mean just
five yards six yards ten yards eight
yards three yards and just moving the
ball at will on that baltimore ravens
defense and those are things we just
haven't seen here in the last year and a
half to where uh it was shocking
even though caleus campbell wasn't there
last year he had been part of it earlier
this year he had some time with injury
that's one of the reasons why you see
and that's not
173 173 i identical rushing yards
allowed the past two weeks both to the
patriots and the tennessee titans and
let me rewind to the incident we saw
beginning the game because i think
there's a way to try to thread it let's
try to thread it with what the ravens
are missing they've lost their edge and
i think that john harbaugh was looking
for something
to get his guys going so he spots a
group of titans players led by malcolm
butler on the crest right it's not their
logo it's their crest at midfield and
harbaugh approaches them
harbaugh goes and gets in their face
there's aj brown i'll tell you more
about what aj brown had to say about the
altercation but i i think that this was
oh don't bring the kicker don't bring
the kicker to a football player fight
coach but
there's there i think was a desire
by harbaugh at some level to spark his
guys because he knows there's an element
of a flat with the ravens right now and
you know it it worked in the first half
it just couldn't hold back the avalanche
all game long right because i think in
sparking his guys he lit a fire under
the titans and it all kind of backfired
on the ravens yesterday it definitely
did and you know you're you're right no
kaleas campbell you know no brandon
williams who's one of the better run
stoppers in football d tackle hey let's
also forget i mean you know people talk
about the ravens and we'll get into
their offense and all that but i mean
hey they're all pro maybe the best left
tackle in football he's not there yonda
retired right they've had to move people
all around so they've had some issues
there and you're right i think john
harbaugh was was probably trying to
manufacture some intensity from his
football team do i think he crossed the
line a little bit with it i do i'm sorry
yeah i do i don't think it's on the
coach to do those type of things sorry
if you want to start to tell your
players hey
that's that's messed up you know that's
effed up over there look at them over
there now what's not messed up or
anything bad about it it wasn't we
haven't seen anything to where i look at
it and go the titans did anything
disrespectful they weren't like
stomping on the emblem in the middle
trying to tear it up they got into a
team huddle which is
happens in every game on the road
anywhere where they're gonna you know
break it down hey we gotta come out here
and play hard today give a hundred
percent blah blah blah blah and then go
into the huddle i mean go into the
locker room before you come out for the
game
that's all that was so that's why i
think you're right like i think harbaugh
was just trying to look for anything to
kind of get started there and i just i
don't think it's the coach's job to do
that and i don't think it's necessarily
the best look for him and he's a guy i
have a tremendous amount of respect for
let's press pause for a second and hear
from both harbaugh and titans coach mike
vrabel from after the game several hours
later regarding what transpired before
kickoff
what was going on with the titans
players and their before and then after
the game
uh after the game there wasn't an issue
i mean coach very blank was down there
celebrating in the end zone then he came
back around and
shook hands before the game it's
irrelevant
i want to celebrate with uh with derek
and the team to congratulate him and
then i ran back and and shook his hand
and um asked what the issue was before
the game and he said uh there wasn't an
issue so i went to celebrate with my
football team
a lot of respect for john we shook hands
but again i i wanted to sprint down
there and be excited with the team and
then just bring it back to midfield
they say the eye in the sky doesn't lie
i don't know maybe sometimes the eye in
the sky misses the handshake because the
video that's widely been making the
rounds yeah you can chose mike
approaching john harbaugh and harbaugh
saying no no so
look i i think that that there's
something going on there but no one
wants to say anything that is going to
become the bulletin board headline going
into a potential playoff rematch if both
teams make it and frankly right now the
ravens got a lot of work to do if they
plan to make it but back to what
happened beforehand of course he's going
to say it's irrelevant because it blew
up in his face aj brown was hilarious
when i was talking to him about this
yesterday he said i'm just out there all
of a sudden they're their coaches are
coming out like yes coaches are
approaching football players like what
did he did are they really doing that he
was stunned and he's like i'm in the
middle of this and if you watch the
video closely he and aj brown may not
even remember he kind of gives a little
push to john harbaugh but uh he said
look that told us this is the way it's
going to be it's going to be a physical
contest and you know he said some people
may not think that makes a difference
but it definitely made a difference
yesterday and it did take a while for it
to pay off yeah but when it paid off it
paid off in a big way yeah and it's not
like you know yeah they were losing in
the first half but they made some
mistakes it wasn't like they were being
bullied or pushed around the field you
weren't like oh man the titans are in
trouble here they're getting totally
dominated they got no chance no they
ryan tannehill made a bad interception
they missed a few passes here or there
but there has got to be something there
i mean first off
these are two
for lack of a better way to say it
tough
meathead type coaches they don't back
down from anybody i mean they they just
don't
and they're not going to say a lot in
post-game press conferences or do
anything like that because they're old
school and they're gonna keep it between
them and all of that but they're they're
both coaches who pride themselves on hey
my team's the bigger badder bully on the
football team and you know are on the
field today and we're gonna show that
we're tougher so there's a clash of
wills there that go on certainly let
alone yeah the ravens
you know in a slump right now
titans ruined their playoff chances last
year they're supposed to be in the super
bowl all those things added into it but
i will go back to what you said with aj
brown very odd i just it's very odd that
uh that a coaching staff gets involved
in that type of thing right there you
know and like i said i don't love that
look for john harbaugh i love his
feistiness but to me that'd be something
where you get your players to be like
hey look at these you know jerks and
blah blah blah and you let them go out
there and get into the confrontation you
don't do that as a head coach
tennessee site and uh titans excuse me
snapped out of the funk that we saw them
slip into
thursday night against the cults it was
a back and forth kind of close game it
felt like the titans were in control a
couple of special teams miscues and that
was that you know derek henry they got
him going it took a while aj brown we
talked about him earlier he was awesome
on the touchdown catch that that really
felt like it gave the titans a lift one
of the great plays of the year as he
bulldozed his way into the end zone
taking patrick queen with him he told me
i just was trying to get the first down
but the the just raw will took over and
he just decided he's taking it all the
way into the end zone and then derek
henry the only player in nfl history
with two overtime touchdowns
in the same season if not ever i gotta
go back and check the stat you don't
have a lot you know overtime games
aren't aren't typical it's usually a
field goal or at least and for years it
was a field goal until they changed the
rules he's got two overtime touchdowns
this year at a minimum it's the most
it's the first time someone's had two
overtime touchdowns in the same season
there's a chance he's one of the very
few to have multiple overtime touchdowns
ever but you know the titans just they
they they they know how to keep it close
and they keep it close and then they
just they they they get you at some
point yeah if they don't blow you out
from the get-go that's their their model
and that's their mindset they're not
going to roll up a ton of points
typically they just are going to be
there and they're going to grind it out
and it's eventually going to bend their
way yeah they're efficient that's what
we usually see them do where we just go
man it's you know
they run the ball for seven eight yards
it's a play action pass for 20 yards and
you just see a lot of drives where you
go oh six or seven 80 yard drive where
you know they just they ripped off a few
chunk plays and that was easy for them
and that's really what happened in the
second half of the football game you
know the titans of course patient with
the run game we're starting to wear the
ravens out and then they have a
play-action pass attack with some
receivers and jonu smith and everybody
else at tight end where you know it it
became too much for the ravens to handle
it did and the ravens started to worry
about that run game and getting bullied
up front so they were putting their db's
in some one-on-one situations and yeah
we don't see them do some of the things
we've seen the last few weeks missed
tackles guys getting pushed back i mean
aj brown breaking all those tackles
doing that i mean uh it's just
unraven-like and then the last piece of
what we don't hit on here or we haven't
hit on yet
is
the ravens offense i you know they're
they have somebody else has to get
involved it can't just be lamar jackson
the run game and mark andrews i don't
know what the ravens expect you're not
going anywhere you're not going anywhere
except for a trip to the playoffs and a
quick exit if they don't find some more
versatility within their offense there
is zero lack of involvement for wide
receivers in their football team it's
almost embarrassing that dez bryant is
your leading receiver okay in the game i
don't you know the receiver i know mark
andrews is the tight end but that that
to me that has got to change there's got
to be more to defend with this ravens
offense people have caught up to the run
game we've talked about their own line
being banged up things like that and
it's not the same as last year so what's
the next move what's the next element
they're going to introduce there's got
to be something else
and look at marquis brown down at the
bottom it was just three weeks ago he
was complaining on twitter and deleting
right it's about his lack of involvement
three targets no catches no yards
there uh yeah they they they
you're right they need and i don't know
is it a quarterback thing or is it a
receiver thing you know we always say
when there's a great receiver and a
great quarterback together which guy is
it when it's not working who do you put
the blame on yeah i'm one to put more on
first off the receiver i always thought
was overrated i mean he played he came
from the flag football conference of the
big 12 and he had kyla murray and baker
mayfield throwing the football okay so
that's gonna make a lot of receivers
look good all right so
that he's plays small but really what i
will go back to
is i just think lack of versatility in
the scheme in the past game too you know
there's just got to be more there and
again with hollywood brown mike i mean
we talked about this a little last week
okay you dropped in the first round give
them a reverse give them a wide receiver
screen do something give them the damn
ball somehow you can't just say oh he
didn't get the ball in the pass game
okay he's fast as hell he's a weapon
he's a first round pick finds some other
ways they got to find more ways to get
the ball into other guys hands other
than andrews lamar jackson and running
backs
uh let's take a break but before we do
just so i because this is bothering me i
want to make sure i get this right derek
henry is the only player with two
overtime touchdowns this year the
all-time record for a career belongs to
ladainian tomlinson he has three
overtime touchdowns so derek henry is
just one away from matching what
ladainian tomlinson did during his
career with overtime touchdowns
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports